the baby the rapper says yeah hardcore
christian church nobody's really gonna
say much yeah but when you have people
who are the lgbtq committee who supports
his music that pays for his bills keeps
his lights on and he goes and says
something like that people are gonna
feel a certain way yeah i feel that bro
i feel it it's um it was
man yeah i guess it it doesn't like
really qualify with this one this one
this one's definitely a specific thing
which yeah that's what i'm saying like
his his main thing that he said was so
specific where i was just like why would
you say those in five four three two one
what's up everybody welcome to an
episode of the genius brain podcast hold
on i left my drink on the goddamn tape
did that
we got a special guest in the house
reoccurring guest the man himself chris
sosa yo yo what up what up stand up
comedian extraordinaire man be cheating
on
yo people still give you [ __ ] about that
oh man
yeah man oh that's uh that's that is
that is a great intro bro appreciate it
man
but they don't know the full story i
don't know
it's still in my back pocket bro still
in my back pocket the full story is nice
you guys won't hear it today but one day
he'll let you know yeah i'll bring it
out man but uh thank you bro thanks for
having me i'm glad i'm glad i'm back bro
glad i'm back and uh it's good to be
here having you [ __ ] with me bro look at
this
i'm like [ __ ] look at this grown ass man
he has a business now if you're out in
the houston area you got to hit up
creative space houston i even know the
whole business name and everything hell
yeah yeah man we had this whole
conversation back in the day about him
wanting to kind of like build a business
and you know it always starts with a
small conversation and then you're one
of the few people that actually follow
through absolutely bro 100 bro just like
cheating bro i commit
i'm sorry i'm sorry i'm sorry
i may not commit to my relationships
but to infidelity i'm sorry man i'm
sorry that's oh man bad joke guys that
was three years ago man my bad damn what
has it been three years yeah bro yeah
holy [ __ ] been a minute bro yeah i've
known you for that long now dude i've uh
i've been yeah i mean i can't yeah i've
been single for like two you know saying
so yeah that's [ __ ] crazy yeah bro
hell yeah man um but i'm sorry like i'm
cutting the whole the whole groove
they're like i don't know if they they
should like me they should hate me
the audience was just like i don't know
how i feel about this guy nah you're
[ __ ] human man [ __ ] happens yeah man
but uh uh thank you bro thanks for for
the love on that bro it's uh it's insane
i have uh i have a a studio i have a
production studio what made you pull the
trigger on it
bro i'm um you know
oh man i'm about to put y'all on the
spot man but i'm super like inspired by
you guys you know what i mean like by
genius brain by uh just kidding films
um kev on stage like i'm
really inspired by the people who you
know take you know they pave their own
way you know i mean they make their own
path and that's really how i am so i'm
like
uh i'm in houston and uh it was supposed
to be just temporary right so
um i'm still you know i'm still making
the money that i'm making out here in la
and i was uh just spending money on an
apartment that just for nothing it was a
pandemic you know what i mean so i'm
just like my really my ego and pride was
just like i'm i'm good i'm still i can
still afford it i'm still out here
pandemic ain't gonna stop me you know
like i'm really just like my ego is just
keeping me here um i was uh i went to go
visit houston um and i was with my
brother and you know i was getting work
done and i was working remotely and my
brother was like wait so you can work
from anywhere i said yeah and he's like
and you're making how much i'm making
this much and he's like and your rent is
how much it's that much he said uh bro
like what do you move back move back bro
like just just uh like use that money
like you could stay here you don't have
to pay no rent and like whenever the
whenever everything opens back up you
can go back and so that was the initial
plan you know you know was interesting
too because all the comedy clubs were
starting to open up in your area yeah
bro so everything kind of just worked
out bro that's what i'm saying bro
cheating was the best thing
[Laughter]
yo she's gonna listen to this [ __ ]
this [ __ ] didn't learn
[ __ ]
if you're a committed man out there
just put your dick in some other vagina
and it'll open up your life it will get
you into places that
that maybe it's like maybe i went into a
place i shouldn't have been and that was
gotten me into places that i need to be
yeah i'm in the happiest place that i
could be
oh my god
you go to hell bro
you go to hell dude
hey bro i wear jackets during the summer
bro i know i don't know how you're
wearing that outfit right now it's
[ __ ] 100 degrees today too cool to be
hot bro
um so look um
so yeah man i i was out there and then i
was in texas and like i said it was
supposed to be temporary and then after
like my first month out there all of
august i was really just like kicking
back i'm back with family i'm gaining
weight i'm hanging out with old
childhood friends and you know just just
like super complacent not really doing
[ __ ] you know what i'm saying and um i
didn't like that i i recognized it i was
like oh [ __ ] i'm uh i'm i'm slacking you
know what i mean as it is in la like you
in l.a you got to figure it out pretty
much every day
and i've had that feeling i've worked
that muscle for seven years out here i
love like just grinding you know i mean
like um and and figuring out how to make
my own money and figuring out how to
move and and different projects to be a
part of so
um
i
i saw this building that has just said
lease on it and i wanted a call just
just to see i was like let me just i
want to see what the numbers are like
you know what i mean like i talked to
you about it you know what i mean and um
what it was when you had your studio and
um saying with just kidding films just
like really peeping like okay i know
that it's possible obviously you know
what i mean so i was just called it up
and and the numbers like i was like wait
that's less than what i was paying for
my apartment in houston yeah i'm sorry
in la and uh and you know as far as like
overhead and expenses and stuff that i
would like have to do after the build
out it came out to be like around the
same number that i was paying for rent
so i was like yo like if i can i can do
that in la i'll do it here in houston
and it'll end up paying for itself
eventually like in the long run yeah but
i have the money to be able to afford it
you know like worst case you know i
don't get i don't get business first
couple months whatever i still just you
know i can afford it yeah and just and
that that's my it's my creative space
bro it's pretty much the any any
creatives like dream to have your own
space your own little world you know to
be able to create and that's a pretty
like scary risk when when people think
about like opening up a business
it's like one of those things where you
you get scared it's just it's kind of
scary it's frightening right because you
don't know what the [ __ ] gonna happen
damn it's uh yeah and really it's really
like you know my family too that add
more uh of the anxiety to it of like you
know where's your business plan or what
do you okay so what do you about this
and what about that and do you have a
plan for this and do you you know all
these things and and my thing was um i'm
just going off of experience and um
really that's it
my main experience like mainly
experience in production experience in
creating content and um and experience
in uh freelance work like being able to
make money um on my own and that's with
those three things i'm like i can do it
and i haven't um like with the momentum
that's going right now it's only been
open for a little bit over a month and i
already have two bookings and i had uh
you know a week worth of production you
know going on in my studio which looked
super dope man it was super tight to
have it feels good huh yeah bro like and
people are complimenting you people are
um you know at my grand opening bro like
was the greatest like feeling it was so
tight bro the the the red ribbon was
like made out of rubber or something
because it didn't go yo the the first
cut didn't happen i was like damn it i
had to kind of like i was really kind of
hitting it but you know we got away with
it it was all it was all love and people
you know were walking in they had their
cell phones and like really like kind of
like in a museum bro you know what i'm
saying and um i have a whole wall
that has posters of me
and um you know narcissistic [ __ ] yeah
yeah bro it's super it's all just
pictures of yourself literally bro just
different like iconic moments that like
you know that and they're you know good
quality photos and stuff but you know at
first the idea was of course i wanted to
have displays right there but i was like
you know
are what legends you know icons am i
gonna put on here stuff like that and
yeah i just was like i'm the legend [ __ ]
it
i was like i inspired myself bro like
honestly genuinely i truly believe in
myself bro so that's i i really have no
you know i already had a a little joke
you know from somebody who actually
booked it you know they they rented the
place and i know we're we're friends
from from from way back but she was like
you like yourself huh and i said a
little bit yeah you know but it's all
love man you don't love yourself you
ain't gonna love anything you know what
i mean yeah i'm with it you're old as
[ __ ] now bro you got a business and [ __ ]
you got things to worry about i do
it's crazy it's crazy but bro you guys
have like 10 businesses bro you know
what i'm saying yeah but i'm ancient
though
i've been around land before time [ __ ]
dude i've been around now i mean i
started opening up businesses because it
was
it's not a fail-safe plan right it's not
like to say that if this whole
entertainment thing doesn't work out
it's more like
i don't want to have to keep working for
a paycheck all the time because
sometimes it gets really exhausting
right because sometimes you just want to
create just to [ __ ] create yeah and
when when you end up creating for a
paycheck all the time you kind of lose
yourself in that right you don't you
don't really get these options to do
what you want because you have to do
what they tell you to do that's what
auditioning's like yeah you're going in
for a role that's albeit sometimes you
don't really [ __ ] with right yeah yeah
man but it's like hey i need to be on a
show i need to go ahead and build my
resume well what happens when that's
like 98 of the [ __ ] that you do now and
only two percent of your life is doing
stuff that you really care about that's
what i'm saying bro like i really can't
roll like that man like i i've gone
through the
the the agent stage i've gone through
the audition stage probably not as much
as like i should you know uh to be able
to say like i i really did that but i
mean i have i've experienced it i know i
know what it's like and you know nobody
takes rejection well i don't take
rejection well and not in a way of like
i don't complain about it i'm just
really good about i'll just i'll just
make my own i'll just make i'll make my
own piece of content i'll be the
characters that i want to be
and i'll do it in the space that i want
to do it and i edit i do i do everything
for it you know that's my that's my
production company it's i do it all
production
llc you know yeah
llc llc
long long car
this [ __ ] dude we got a big dick
got pictures of himself and he cheats
[ __ ] a piece of [ __ ] oh man
yeah but that's it's interesting though
but a lot of people don't don't have
that um
i think it's it's like my greatest
example is uh the critiques from the
olympics everybody is that person where
they look at somebody at the olympics
right they sit around that you guys look
just like me yeah yeah yeah we sit down
the couch going like
look at that landing
terrible yeah who the [ __ ] are you guys
you know but everybody's a [ __ ]
critic yeah and a lot of the times it's
easier just to sit down and judge what
somebody else does and really go and do
it for yourself yeah because it's
[ __ ] scary you got to take those
risks right and and it's for those
people who don't take failure really
well too right i think a lot of people
who kind of i like i have a relative who
failure is something that he didn't
really experience until later on in his
life is because he was coddled for a
majority of it mom and dad would always
come through and say hey like you're the
best you're super smart you can do
anything that you want and generally
when he hit something or he did
something he always achieved it well
later on it found out that life got a
little tough right he uh dropped out of
college and he took that super hard
ashamed lied to every about everybody
about his schooling said that he was
still in school uh he was still killing
it or whatever the guy dropped out
didn't tell anybody and the the the the
disappointing part about that too was
that none of us would have ever judged
him for dropping out or not doing well
it was the fact that he did that and he
pretended like he was in school for two
years
and i'm like you have any idea how
[ __ ] stressful that is for you to sit
here and lie for two years pretending
like you're in school don't do it bro
it's like this fool would like pretend
to go to the library he's like i'm
studying and he would sit in the library
do nothing oh bro he would actually do
the he's actually going about his life
but not doing it there's like bro maybe
you should be the actor in the family
because you are a method actor to the
max damn like i'm talking dude there was
a dude in college
that i knew that also did this as well
when i was in riverside so he
this [ __ ] would play ball all
the time like all the time and i knew
he wasn't like we got a little
suspicious so we actually just followed
him around one day to see what he's
doing he's like oh i got to hit this
midterm and then he would like get up in
his little school backpack put books and
[ __ ] in it and whatever and then we'll
follow him and he goes into the
basketball gym i'm like i thought he had
a midterm so this full dropped out of
riverside for a whole year but he was
living with us in the apartment for a
year but he didn't go to the school yeah
because he was he was already kicked out
after the first year because he was on
academic probation
but he did the whole get up
get up he would put on his [ __ ]
little school shirt or whatever he's in
college by the way yeah put his backpack
on hey guys i'm studying today like you
would say it out loud
man midterm is going to be tough this
week
he would walk out like i'm like why is
he announcing this stuff this seems so
fake turns out the guy was kicked out
after the first year and he was just
going out every day during the times
that he was supposed to be in class
playing basketball at the gym i can't
imagine bro like that you have to be a
sociopath yeah bro to really like go
like through that and and have to stick
with that lie for so long bro yeah i
mean
it's uh uh
is this the whole episode gonna be about
my cheating yeah
it's like oh my god cheating on a woman
okay but no i'm saying um man it's uh it
just just like
it it's very liberating bro to just like
just be
like true to yourself you know say like
that's what i really learned like in
this whole
pandemic uh and everything that i've
i've achieved and gotten out of it you
know what i mean like at first i was
kind of like you know
real hard on myself as you know as we
all are you know as far as like
creatives and stuff so
i um i forget to step back and look at
like what i've done you know what i'm
saying and i'm so focused on like
tomorrow or like what's what's what i
have to get done it's all these things
but
um
just being able to like you know move
the way i want to move and like and be
the person that i want to be and be
happy with it you know what i'm saying
like i couldn't imagine like sticking in
that and that uh that that life and
trying to be something that i'm not like
saying all that to say that i'm gay
he wasn't cheating
he was just being himself he was finding
himself inside a penis
that's just [ __ ] crazy yeah bro this
podcast is brought to you by candid why
are your teeth the way they are right
now do you hate the fact that your teeth
look like they're throwing up gang signs
do they look like plymouth rock maybe it
looks like you threw 30 tic tacs in your
damn mouth and you super glue them to
your freaking gums well no more my
friends because we are talking about can
did while poorly reviewed or insanely
priced clear aligner companies use
general dentist cannon only works with
orthodontist my friends your treatment
is prescribed and closely monitored
remotely by a licensed orthodontist
who's an expert in tooth movement you
can book an appointment at a candid
studio near you or you could even do it
from the comfort and convenience of your
own home canon can help you get the
straighter brighter smile you've always
wanted right now you can save 75 on your
candid starter kit when you get started
from home or you can book an appointment
at a candid studio near you today go to
candidco.com
brain and use codebrain that's candid
co.com
brain codebrain take advantage of this
limited time offer to save 75 on your
starter kit that's candid co.com
brain code brain
no but it's hard like when i when i do
like instagram lives or something
everybody always asks is like how do i
find myself it's like that's a that's a
process and journey that we're going to
go through for the rest of our lives
yeah one of the biggest mistakes that i
think a lot of young people think they
think that you're going to figure out
what you are and then that's what you're
going to be for the rest of your life
that changes yeah that script flips fast
all the time man i was supposed to be a
gap underwear model many years ago hey
man you still can be bro listen man you
still can't like burritos and hamburgers
way too much it's just not gonna [ __ ]
happen i'm giving up i ate 17 pounds of
indian food just two hours ago but i've
given up it's not gonna happen but like
people people think that their idea of
who they are
is like set in stone like sometimes like
people will look at like oh you're so
successful how'd you figure out what
you're gonna be for the rest of your
life i don't know if this is what i'm
going to be for the rest of my life
right as of right i've done everything
that i wanted to do i wanted to create a
film i want to do this open up a
business tomorrow i don't know i might
be making ceramics yeah yeah like here's
what's his name um uh seth rogen yeah
he's just doing well ceramics exactly
some weird [ __ ] here's something else
too like i started taking boxing really
seriously right yeah turns out i hate
that [ __ ]
bro i look bro
i really want to beat the [ __ ] out of
you bro
you're getting really good at it and i'm
like oh let me tell you something you're
getting cocky a little bit i'm like you
know what hey chris let me tell you
something i ain't about that life
i found out real fast
it's hard
it's
hard like i'm good one round second
round your boy guessed is it yeah all i
got
and it's weird because i wanted to see
what it's like right like if i wanted to
be a boxer i wanted to take this
seriously even if i just take one lesson
i want to see the the training regimen
of what it takes in like an hour or two
hour session right yeah let me tell you
something
it sucks so [ __ ] bad
hate it i [ __ ] hate it and i'm
sitting here after i'm done i go back i
go to my car i turn on the ac i take a
three hour nap
and then i leave leave the parking lot
and i'm like why the [ __ ] who why would
somebody do this for a living like this
is so hard yeah bro it's that that
discipline bro it's that [ __ ] mike tyson
talk about it you have to want it you
have to want it to put your body through
that type of [ __ ] yeah to get punched in
the face to be heaving and the thing is
too when you train boxing it never gets
easier it's harder yeah every [ __ ]
time yeah and then you learn something
new because if you're in shape then
that's a bad thing because now we have
to now we have to extend you have to go
further you know yeah it's just this
never gets easier yeah and i assume that
it was going to get easier yeah it just
never did so i'm like oh i could tell
i'm not about that life this is this is
not you know it all just depends on what
your goal is because it can it can be
easy as far as like training
recreationally you know what i'm saying
but you know you're you're really
pushing you're with people who who push
you as well you know i mean shout out to
nick and your other trainers and stuff
they don't push you bro you know what
i'm saying and so we but the thing about
being us and nick we [ __ ] around
we're having fun yeah you know yeah but
when somebody
is like a coach
that like wants something out of you
there's no fun i'm like trying to i'm
like trying to do stand up
trying to distract him and [ __ ] it was
like hey two guys walking to a bar he's
like shut the [ __ ] up three two one
i'm like oh
[ __ ] this guy doesn't give a [ __ ] about
me yeah bro damn man yeah i mean but i
mean i i love it i i still i mean
actually since i've been back home i've
have i've like worked out as far as like
you know going off for runs stuff like
that or stuff i can do like at the crib
but i haven't hit the the boxing gyps
the gyms yet you know i don't know
because a part of me feels like i'm
gonna get that bug again and i'm gonna
be wanting to be in it like bro like
that that old school like video that i
put out yeah that home video
and actually like had me and like teared
up when i was watching the real like all
the whole fight you know i mean i'm back
in it and um uh for those who don't know
like i have it on my on my ig page on ig
tv but i have uh some old school like
home videos of me boxing back in o2 and
it's like so serious bro no there's no
games you know the way my dad's in my
corner and talking to me and like you
know i remember those fights too and um
you know getting robbed that first fight
and then coming back to to win that
second fight but that that world man of
of being uh in in boxing and uh so it's
just i just i was just like looking at
lil chris like man bro like you're
really in there fighting bro like it
seems like i was fighting for my life
with the belt when the bell rings and
i'm just in there and really bro we're
eight we're nine or ten whatever you
know just throwing just going at it but
just like i remembered you know that's
what got me kind of teary-eyed because i
was just like oh my god bro like when
they said my name when they when they
when i when i lost and i was looking at
my dad like bro like i thought i thought
we won this you know but i was really
trying to look at my dad for the answers
and my dad even told me he was like son
he was like i was watching that and that
kind of messed me up when i saw you look
at me because he was like i remembered
what it what it was like when that
happened you know i was looking at my my
son where i'm like i don't know what to
tell you like this that's that's how it
goes you know and uh and and we came
back and then that's how you know when
he he picked me up and you know i kind
of got a little scared when he when he
hopped in the ring i know what was going
on he you know picked me up and stuff
and it was like a [ __ ] you know uh uh
the classic movie it started yeah and
then i put the dramatic you know music
in the back i thought that was a nice
little touch just to be you know silly
but it was cool man uh um that's that's
that's just a passion bro and just
having that discipline you know that
lifestyle's so [ __ ] hard man like i
think for me once i hit my third session
yeah and it was literally the night
before and the first thing i thought was
like do i have like tuberculosis do i
have aids do i have some form of cancer
that i could tell my coach that i can't
come in this morning and i was like damn
i'm really i'm looking for every excuse
not to come in yeah but then you know
the other part of me is like i already
paid for 10 sessions so the asian side
of me is like you already paid you guys
your money's
but i wanted to uh i wanted to [ __ ] with
you man i and that's why like i when i
have specific jokes with you i have to
dm you you know cuz i'm like i don't
know how to gauge it you know i mean
obviously they you know they probably
know me from the podcast and stuff like
that but you know you know how it is bro
so i'll but i wanted to [ __ ] with you
bro because i knew that the boxing
you're getting you're getting in shape
bro like you know you look good the
boxing like you really like your form
and everything's looking nice and then
it was also during the time where you
know uh which is obviously nothing to
joke about but you know the asian hate
and yeah yeah yeah so going on and
you're going in right like you beat
whoever i'm like what's up you know i
did whatever i just wanted to hit you up
like bro i will [ __ ] you up bro [ __ ] you
that would have been like yeah you
probably would
i was like probably
most likely yes oh but i couldn't i
wanted to make my own video like i did
and just and just tag you like just call
you out like i wanted to like call you
out i was just being like you're right
period
probably oh man but that's our own
that's our own humor like boxing is so
weird too because it's like
there's just so much things to do
in a short period of time that you can't
not do like
you always have to move your head head
movement you got to be aware your foot
placement like you know what i mean your
foot where everything has to be on point
yeah and then you also have to do that
when you're [ __ ] exhausted because
everybody looks amazing in the first 30
seconds like you look good you're
[ __ ] weaving you're slipping you're
moving and then you get a little tighter
than your head
it's like i'm gonna keep it right yeah
i'm gonna keep it right here when he
comes in i'm gonna hit him with that
check hook
but really what's happening i get my
face jacked up i'm gonna hit him with my
face i'm gonna hit my face i'm gonna hit
his glove with my face i've been talking
that [ __ ] like there's how your fists
feel on my face bro
yeah i bet your fist hurts a lot [ __ ]
yeah i'm bleeding out the side of my
mouth bro it's hard yeah man and i'm
also at the weight right now that i
would never compete at like i would
compete probably i would drop like
another 30 pounds isn't that crazy bro
like that that fight would pat bro i
weighed in at 159 mayweather goes in at
147.
what you don't say like canelo's at 147
and they're jacked yeah bro jacked yeah
it's just it's just i mean that's just
how no body no uh a body fat because you
know what a boxer looks like with their
215 pounds they don't look like this no
you know they they look six foot four
jacked out of their [ __ ] mind like
that's what they look like i would have
to drop like another 30 or 40 pounds and
honestly i probably could be there and
still be happy like 215 i would have to
be dieseled up how do you feel about
this um about the um the celebrity
boxing like
thing that's going on like that i mean
they got it up the tyron woodley and
jake paul thing it's about to happen
right yes you know
the funny thing is is also logan paul is
going to box anderson silva and and so
anderson silva is a legendary mma
fighter right but he's 46 years old uh
retired with a huge losing streak on his
record right but
he was the longest reigning like
middleweight champ in the ufc like i
think it was i think the streak was like
nine or ten years okay nobody could
[ __ ] beat him yeah and then age and
time got him yeah but he just fought uh
julio chavez jr okay and he beat his ass
he beat his ass yeah yeah like [ __ ]
crazy yeah well because anderson silva
what people don't know he actually does
have a boxing background he started in
boxing first okay and he was an amazing
striker in mma but nobody's actually
seen anderson silva just use his hands
if you look up online right now you'll
see uh freddie roach actually cornering
anderson silva uh i think it was in wild
card oh no and you see freddie roach
coaching him and you see anderson silla
just beating the [ __ ] out of a pro boxer
and it's like when anderson civil was
like 39 or 40. he's like 46 now right so
he's gonna fight logan paul
and um
logan paul's going to be in for a rude
rude awakening yeah bro because you got
to you just have to understand that
[ __ ] um
anderson silva just boxed somebody who
just boxed not like a couple years ago
just boxed canelo and it was pretty
competitive yeah so and he beat his ass
so i just i just i don't like um
like i i definitely think it's fun bro i
think it's fun i'm not the guy who's
like they're messing up boxing and
they're ruining the the disrespecting no
no no i think it's fun bro think that i
think that they definitely created a
whole new lane um that like celebrity
boxing was a thing but it wasn't really
like you know you didn't really like
really paid to watch it you know um
and but i i just with the paul brothers
i i just i would hate for it to be like
so much in the paperwork and so much in
the the contracts and stuff like that
that like
excuse me they're really just like
putting on a show and they have to win
you know what i'm saying because i just
don't
mayweather
you know
the that's why i don't watch the
mayweather one yeah what am i here to
watch i i guess we're here to watch that
one percent chance that logan paul
knocks out floyd mayweather right but
really it's not gonna happen so yeah i
didn't pay for it like that's not
something i care to watch i got to see
probability when i see like youtubers
box youtubers is way more fun yeah
because the skill level is the same
right exactly when you see somebody like
okay so like jake paul too right he's
obviously calling out people who aren't
boxers right
and the only one that i've been
interested in i've never paid to watch a
single jake paul boxing match i only
watched the aftermath the only one that
i am gonna watch now though is tyron
woodley and jake paul this one this one
makes sense yeah because tyler woodley
actually has hands yeah this is what
he's known for right his boxing's
actually pretty good right and because
he's an mma fighter and he's he's like
40 what 40 years old
it's more competitive yeah you know so i
could see them going toe to
and i i want the odds look really funny
yeah i'm excited for that one bro cause
i'm really like okay i don't think that
he would do a whole like you know a fake
fight situation like mayweather you know
i mean like they and mayweather you know
he he let it be known too he was just
like yo i got paid for this fake fight
like yeah [ __ ] it you know what i'm
saying like call it a heist yeah yeah it
was it was a check you know what i'm
saying and and it made total sense um
this one i i feel like nah like it ain't
they're not he's not at a mayweather
level to just want to just be like i'll
do this fake fight no i think he's for
real like you know what's crazy too like
i don't think people realized how much
bigger logan paul was
he was twice
i was like holy [ __ ]
this looks this looks like a joke yeah
bro it looked like rocky uh three or
four what was it when you fought the
german yeah yeah bro it looked like that
it was ridiculous
i'm like oh damn the size difference is
[ __ ] nuts yeah even with like him
letting like with mayweather letting him
hit him i'm like bro dude those hurt
because yeah you know what i'm saying
like that's a big guy bro he's just
taking those blows you know what i'm
saying but i mean [ __ ] man you know
people were like how come he didn't
knock logan paul i was like well also he
has a hundred pounds on him so it's to
take a little more to knock them out but
a lot of those hits
hit him hard yeah you know mayweather
hasn't knocked anybody out in a minute
you know and also mayweather's like what
44 years old yeah like come on
right yeah but it was it was it's kind
of crazy too when you look at his legacy
too like people might say like that
tarnishes mayweather's legacy but it's
kind of cool to see somebody that old
beat the [ __ ] out of somebody that young
twice his size and it's not like logan
paul doesn't train boxing either yeah
you know and he's not a terrible boxer
for what he does you know for the level
of training that he has yeah no yeah
they're they're they're killing it bro
yeah give them credit you know yeah
they it's not like anybody's going to
walk up on in the middle of the street
and knock out logan paul or jay paul
they'll light your ass up they got it i
got it i gave it to them for sure yeah
but their big boys are strong they're
young i think they're like 23 and 24.
they're [ __ ] young crazy bro they
they they
definitely figured it out whatever that
whatever like scheme or this podcast is
brought to you by better help if you
haven't focused on your mental health my
friends this year and this time is the
time to start listen we all been cooped
up intense and honestly we all know the
importance of our mental health so stop
pushing your feelings and thoughts aside
man and get the help you need better
help will assess your needs and match
you with your own licensed professional
therapist you don't have to sit in an
uncomfortable waiting room and you can
message your counselor at any time while
setting up weekly video or phone
sessions it's super convenient and more
importantly allows you to be in your own
safe and comfortable environment see
i've used betterhelp and it was honestly
an amazing experience and i still use
and talk to my counselor till this day
so give it a try you have nothing to
lose and you have a whole bunch to gain
i love it this podcast is sponsored by
better help and genius brain listeners
get 10 off their first month at
betterhelp.com genius so visit
b-e-t-t-e-r-h-e-l-p-com
genius to get that 10 off and work on
that mental health baby blueprints that
they got bro they they figured it out
bro and it's uh would you do who would
you want to box celebrity boxing oh bro
um i i've always said i wanted to fight
uh justin bieber because he was boxing
with mayweather and he had he was like
in the boxing game and you know i would
for sure he would beat his ass i saw a
clip of that full boxing he sucks i
would get in the ring with justin bieber
i would get in the ring with chris brown
because he also said you know he also
trains boxing stuff like that and he you
know he's shown he's posted videos of
him doing the pads and stuff like that
and
you know it's just
you know and i'm a huge like chris brown
fan like you know this guy's a legend i
just
i just you know let me get that you know
what i want you to box i want you to box
this one youtuber name
i don't might be mispronouncing his name
his name is adam something adam salad a
lot of uh
youtubers i think he's like uh i think
he's like
is he the cat that he does he's
literally his youtube is like uh you
know his life and it's like uh it's like
relationship and he's like i only know
about him because
he was doing videos with that guy yousef
and yousef also did celebrity boxing
okay but this guy adam is an actual
boxer he's like you he actually has an
amateur record oh no it has hands okay
so you two would actually match up
really [ __ ] well and you guys are
about the same size yeah okay yeah yeah
yeah
adam [ __ ] chris called you a little
[ __ ] ass [ __ ] yeah go get this yeah
there you go he says he's gonna beat yo
[ __ ] ass could i set it up
[Laughter]
i want to see if it happens we'll see
what happens bro i mean yeah bro i'm uh
i'm all for it man i definitely i have
to have a big fight bro like in my in my
career bro in my journey i want to have
a big fight bro just
because you know obviously sanctioned in
a ring you know the real deal but yeah
hell yeah bro i've always wanted to do
that since i was younger i wanted to be
a professional boxer so it's like you
better train dude oh bro let me tell you
something bro
[Laughter]
cause i know i know you're gonna hear
this all right
i think about that fight every night
[Laughter]
i haven't stopped thinking about that
fight since i heard the decision
i want you back so bad
you better train [ __ ] this one
came in looking fat as [ __ ] i was like
yo putting your shirt back on
bro
there were people like and i'm back in
houston bro and like you know they were
like yo don't you got a fight coming up
straight up like i'm like i'm like two
micheladas in
don't you gotta fight i'm like i'll be
good bro it's fun bros comics versus
comics bro it's fun it's gonna be as
smart as you know that
not knowing pat's in there [ __ ] going
in doing road work she's training
and and y'all's corner too man you know
and that actually made me feel pretty
good you know what i'm saying because i
was like look at that they they had a
whole team man working their ass off
against me you know and and their and
their strategy you know they're calling
out codes and stuff you know what i'm
saying i was just in the corner like my
word people are getting punched
she saw my face i was like oh my god
i was like are you okay
man i'm nervous dude yeah man i wanted
it bro i wanted it man gassed out and i
don't have any other excuse bro just
gasps just a lot of taco bell belly
going into the [ __ ] i was like
i was like what are you doing in houston
that's right that's what i'm saying bro
i was i was i was [ __ ] eating you
know what i'm saying
i was just eating bro eating good i'm
with the family family
of the quarter he just like i don't know
what to tell you son
bro for real like you're tired i was
just like yo don't even be mad at that
yo like just don't even be mad it's all
good i'm like i'm like for real pissed
bro like my dad's like yo like this was
fun it was like it's pretty cool he was
like you just gassed out
nobody was throwing hard ass haymakers
and it was just it was like 70 percent
pop pop pop yeah it was fun i i
personally was nervous as [ __ ] yeah yo
you know who was on that card that i
didn't realize you know the dude that
beat the [ __ ] out of the other guy jamar
neighbors yeah bro
and he was on joe rogan and he talked
about it yeah well i've seen i know of
jamar neighbors i didn't know that was
because he had a head gear on yeah i was
like who is this man
yeah beating the [ __ ] out of this game
and i was i felt so bad bro because you
know jamar even said shout out to jamar
man he's funny as [ __ ] he actually
absolutely he's also on um you know the
the roast battles like on on comedy
central like i think he co broke
produced it you know he was like one of
the starters on that um and he was on
joe rogan talked about how they even
pulled up his fight i think um joe rogan
oh they talked about the the
comic versus comic fight hilarious yeah
i thought that was like super tight um
and uh who who who's asked did he
[ __ ] up man i forgot the guy's name man
bobrecito guy he was just ah rest in
peace man yeah recipes to his ribs um uh
jamar literally was like man honestly i
was gonna take it light but he posted
like the day before saying like uh
he like on the caption which you can
just like honestly bro it's a caption i
feel like he just did it just to like
sell the fight sell the fight and you
know say something i think he said it
beat his ass bro jamar was like i took
it personal i was like relax mj
take it easy jamar he was like yeah i
took a personal base like what did he
write he said fights tomorrow guys
just matter of fact
i fight tomorrow guys i love my family
see you there did you say that like i
don't love my family like i don't have a
family to go back to yeah exactly bro
and i was just like bro i was watching
him just like dig in this guy's he's
punching his left side his gloves coming
out of the right bro
and i'm like oh my god dude at a certain
point jamar grabbed the back of his neck
yeah
oh yeah poor guy i was like holy [ __ ]
jamar boxes too that's what i'm saying
he trained yeah train trains yeah so
it's like yo what kind of mismatch is
this dude the other dude you could tell
never trained the day in his life the
worst matchup ever why would they ever
do that to that poor guy i don't know
that [ __ ] hurt yeah looking at him that
[ __ ] was all bad dude yeah and jamar's
yoked yeah bro he's [ __ ] yeah he's
yolk bro yeah he's like hood i only do
pull-ups outside in the [ __ ] beach
yolk he does pull-ups on the on the
street signs
[Laughter]
don't beat my ass tomorrow
[Laughter]
no you bad funny bro don't beat my eyes
seriously you look crazy yeah man yeah
bro but but man yeah man i'm i'm
i'm back in houston but i've been here
i've been here uh for
was it three days now and um
[ __ ] i forgot how much like i i took la
for granted uh uh a bit you know like
the weather
won the weather that's the main thing
yeah like i'm gonna lay down i'm just
like bro
this [ __ ] feels fantastic
like houston is a swamp bro it's humid
as [ __ ] right now humid and just
it'll rain and it's just like hot rain
you're just like yo this is ain't what's
up um it's cool to be back with the fan
but i'm back here now i'm i'm back in
l.a i'm just like damn i used to live
here and i i was just like
jake the world just goes crazy though it
doesn't matter where you're at man did
you hear about that [ __ ] with uh [ __ ]
the baby
oh bro yeah i um
damn man it's a it's so like uh it's
crazy to like um how
you know to talk about this the angle of
it because if like if you try to go
about like you know
well i mean it's just this and that then
you come off as like well you're
defending and you're agreeing with what
he's saying which isn't that's which
isn't the case but you know they're it's
a little aggressive they're they're kind
of like they're kind of i gotta bring up
what the [ __ ] he said i was what was he
yeah it wasn't a lollapalooza was it no
it was um what was it what was it for i
forget the um what festival it was but
he
basically was saying you know put your
lights in the air if
um if you don't have aids if you don't
have hiv right yeah and then and then he
said um put your light in the air if uh
oh this is what he said right here he
goes during his set at the florida-based
event the baby seemingly praised male
attendees for not sucking dick after
saying if you didn't show up today with
hiv aids or any of them deadly sexually
transmitted diseases that'll make you
die in two to three weeks then put your
cell phone ladder up
yeah
and he was just
it's so specific ain't it like
it's like
hold up guys yeah and then the song he
drops
you know he uh uh
it's like it seems so oh you got it
fellas if you ain't sucking [ __ ] dick
in the parking lot put yourself on like
this
who should be he should be getting the
most
flat cuz like the ad libs are so
unnecessary
man for ribs some of y'all suspect man
low key
what if the babies are the corn like hey
shut the [ __ ] up
making this worse
yeah i'm just trying to preach about
some [ __ ] but you make it ten times
worse i don't get like why it was like
it was really specific of what he was
like requesting of the the people who
were lifting for real you know and i
also like wanted to see the audience of
like how many people had their hands up
you know i want to see everybody with
them cell phone lights up that's what
i'm saying i wanted to see who you know
and then and then it's like
um
like okay so
aside from the actual incident
i the the idea of
it being so
cool or like it's the thing now to be
offended like you just like like the the
thing to do is to be offended like for
for anything something could be
offensive you know what i'm saying we
probably i've probably said 10 offensive
things in this podcast already
but um
yo like it's the it's the context of so
much of a person to really gauge like
are they really being offensive you know
what i'm saying i really like and i'm
not like super educated on this stuff
i'm just like this is just genuinely
like how i'm feeling of like yo like you
like
what are you really it's actually cooler
to be not offended you know what i'm
saying it's cooler to be able to take a
joke you know it's cooler to be able to
take in oh but this one wasn't a joke
though okay well that wasn't a joke yeah
i was like i feel like if he was making
a joke a lot of people be like he's just
being a dumbass right but he's out the
the problem with it is too that he
doubled down right yeah about his his
like beliefs because he put out like a
semi-fake apology after where i gotta
refine that up too let me find that the
one that like his pr probably typed up
no this is the one that his so his pr
type something else different but after
he did his own apology so
he uh he basically said
uh where is it so he offered a pseudo
apology for his remarks last week and is
giving what is supposed to give music
video don't fight hate with hate my
apologies for being me the same way you
want the freedom to be you yeah so it's
like
he's saying that he
listen
i i think the problem with that is that
he's a musician with a platform right
and everybody should be everybody gets
held responsible for the [ __ ] that they
say yeah but when we have like
specifically like i think people in the
black community are very upset because
hiv and everything else has been an
issue within the like the black gay
community and so when he goes ahead and
says that it kind of puts like a green
light on them it's like yeah [ __ ] these
[ __ ] gay people right it's not what
he's saying but i think people are
worried about the ripple effect somebody
with that type of huge audience and
power has so
when he does something like that and
yeah you can think whatever the [ __ ] you
want to think and you could say whatever
you want to say because i'm pretty sure
that there are some hardcore christians
out there that are like yup that thing
is against god's will
he's a musician you're in a musician's
space you're not in a religious space
right so
i think for him he also has to
understand the platform in which he says
it allows for backlash yeah pretty sure
if he said that probably in a hardcore
christian church
the baby the rapper says in the hardcore
christian church nobody's really going
to say much but when you have people who
are in the lgbtq committee who supports
his music that pays for his bills keeps
his lights on and he goes and says
something like that people are going to
feel a certain way yeah i feel that bro
i feel it it's um it was
man yeah i guess it doesn't like really
qualify with this one this was this
one's definitely a specific thing which
yeah that's what i'm saying like his his
main thing that he said was so specific
where i was just like why would you say
those specific words together and at
that moment because it's crazy because i
guarantee now he's like [ __ ] why the
[ __ ] did i say that yeah you know what
i'm saying like why did i say that you
know some of y'all suspect as [ __ ] yo dj
even though yeah even though yeah the
guy the hype guy he's like you know
nobody's talking about him at all
nobody's saying one word about that guy
you know what i'm saying some of y'all
suspect for real you know what i'm
saying like and and um and and also like
who was he really directing that to like
the baby like who was he really like
like yeah it's just a weird thing too
because the funny thing is i heard like
t.i backed him up yeah t.i was saying um
you know people should be able to i mean
kind of the same thing that debatey said
like you know they should be able to
speak you know how they feel because oh
because they said he basically said if
it's okay for
uh little niles x to express himself and
go you know go all out and and you know
it's kind of like it's another thing
about being offended but they're like
why why are y'all being offended he's
being himself um it's he's like use that
same energy on
on the baby or somebody who is what are
you i guess a little nazix yeah no
nonsex you know what i'm saying like
it's basically just i have that same
energy and um
i don't know i don't know like i really
don't know how to phrase what the hell i
was trying to because i think the
biggest difference is the reason why
that comparison to me just off the top
doesn't make too much sense is because
little nas x
is
saying stuff in support of who he is
he's not condemning straight people for
being straight
he's the baby's thing is he's expressing
himself freely but he's condemning gay
people for being gay you see what i'm
saying so nila nazax is expressing who
he is yeah i'm gay i suck dick i do gay
[ __ ] yeah that's what i do right if look
if the baby was going like i'm a
straight man i [ __ ] women i like [ __ ]
women and people like [ __ ] you yeah then
it would be a similar person
that one to me doesn't make too much
sense if you would never put a dick in
your mouth put the light you know saying
like some [ __ ] like that yeah so if he's
talking about like being oh like him
being proud of being straight either way
still would have got some flack i'm
guessing but that would be a more
similar comparison because little
nasdaq's expressing the fact that he
likes men and he's sucking dick doesn't
condemn straight people for being
straight yeah i mean so he's making the
stance of homosexuality being wrong is
suspect as [ __ ] it's disgusting it's
gross that's what it's coming off as and
so for him like i said it kind of also
goes back to who's your audience you
know gay people listen to your [ __ ]
music too yeah you know they're out here
[ __ ] grinding probably sucking dick
to it too so
and then you go ahead and you alienate
this audience who have been supporting
you people are going to feel a certain
way about it you know if he was off the
jump starting off hey it's your boy the
baby i don't [ __ ] with gay people
then i guess that's what it is yes
and you gain your popularity off of that
then yeah then let's have a conversation
about that right but you were fine
having all these people support you do
whatever and then out of nowhere your
opinions about the gay community comes
out it's like
in the same coin it's like you can say
whatever you want people also can
respond the way they want to by the [ __ ]
that you say yeah so it kind of works
both ways right so it's like a weird
space like i i don't like t.i even
jumping in in the first place is like
bro what are you doing aren't you too
busy telling your [ __ ] daughter to be
a virgin
yeah testing her vagina to see if she's
still a virgin you [ __ ] weirdo yeah
it's just it's just crazy bro that like
you know
words bro like words you put them in
certain like combinations like we just
talked about right now if he would have
flipped it this way it would have been
all right but it's like it's just it's
just crazy because it's like um
it's uh it's quick to just be like all
right he's done that that's it he's not
gonna be done he's not you know me and
he knows he's not and and and the way
that he's playing it also is like one of
those like bro just put the phone down
dog like yeah just enough you're doing
it you know what i'm saying like you
know um also like apologies they could
go quicker if you if if you're if you're
really not gonna apologize then don't
[ __ ] apologize because it makes it
worse it makes it worse well because my
thing is like he ended up apologizing
and it's like
bro that you could have did that
literally the next day you know what i'm
saying and sincerely like on camera and
hold yourself accountable the next show
you let them know like you do a whole
psa you know what i mean you may be able
to you know get through and that's where
it's like well people aren't perfect no
for the longest he was just like man
[ __ ] y'all no this is this i'm the baby
and then ends up apologizing you're like
bro makes you look ten times worse it
makes it worse bro like stick to what
you're doing or just move on but see
that's the thing too is like when once
you start hurting somebody's pockets
they feel a certain way
you know they're like oh [ __ ] like my
money's disappearing yeah what should i
really [ __ ] do yeah or you could just
shut the [ __ ] up and then you just kind
of move on or you stick you stick your
ground and that's it right i have never
apologized for any [ __ ] that i put out
bro that's what i wanted to talk to you
about i'm so glad you brought that up i
wanted to say like you know
with your brand and everything that you
that you've done been on and big
networks and stuff like that um
uh during the time of i mean obviously
of like uh like
asian hate and those videos that you put
up very passionate and very you know you
you really feel this way genuinely is um
uh does that ever like does any you know
anybody reach out to be like hey you
kind of relax a little bit or like yeah
i mean i know a lot of people feel that
way you know and there's a reason why a
lot of like asian americans didn't say
something until it was cool to say
something until everybody else came on
this bandwagon i was talking about it
with the homie china mac about it right
yeah it's like
unless it was popular and people could
really benefit from it nobody really
said anything right but before that
conversation was like hey tone it down a
little bit man
like i get what you're doing you don't
have to be all out but then suddenly all
these like abc nbc networks were hopping
on this bandwagon they're like yeah i
feel this way too you [ __ ] [ __ ] made
[ __ ] you never felt this way
about [ __ ] yeah you were quiet because
it wasn't important to you enough for
you to speak up about it because you're
a [ __ ] [ __ ] that's what it is yeah
so for me yeah
i never came about this space to be
famous so
fame it is just a byproduct of me doing
what i want to do so if i'm famous from
it then i'm famous for it if i'm not i'm
not i don't really [ __ ] care yeah
like those videos blew up they got
millions of views i could care less
i literally could [ __ ] care less
and in fact what happened was that a lot
of people expected to see more content
like that and they're like oh where's
this content at or they expected me to
be this extra woke person they found out
that i wasn't yeah and they're like oh
and then i gained like 200 000 followers
on instagram and then like 50 000 of
them dropped it's like cool i don't want
you here anyways yeah i never really
cared in the first place
so i can't make moves based on like
i just don't want to apologize for those
things i'll apologize for things that i
genuinely [ __ ] up on where i feel
terrible gotcha but if i feel like i
just either made a joke and the joke was
appropriate and it was laid out right
i can't be upset for the fact that
you're upset about the joke
i'm sorry you have every right to
dislike it as long as i did my best and
did my due diligence to understand that
uh i didn't do it in a hurtful or
harmful way and it was just you out of
like
i don't know 98 people yeah that were
offended by it and that's a you problem
yeah if like 98 people were offended and
one person left maybe the joke wasn't
funny and i was just being offensive
right you know okay but that has yet to
happen yet so yeah
okay yeah because i was uh yeah i was
always like not always but just curious
about that you know what i'm saying like
you're very you're very um you know uh
uh outspoken in a way of like you're
just true to what you like who you are
and what you feel you're gonna say
exactly how you feel which is super dope
um i didn't know it was actually like
just asking for advice of like how how
much you can go without worrying about
like because you know like bro kevin
hart the way he talks now is like you
know he'll even break from him and be
like man we have to say this stuff now
like i'm sorry ahead of time and you
know and it's kind of like you know
before before you what you're about to
say you have to like you know be pc and
all these things and i've never ever had
that vibe from you you just go off of
like yo this is just well it's also
because i'm also not kevin hart you know
like kevin yeah the reason why kevin
hart has his level of success is because
he tiptoes really really [ __ ] well
yeah even with his last special right
his last special was what what was it
called i don't give a [ __ ] or yeah zero
[ __ ] zero [ __ ] giving or whatever and
there was plenty of [ __ ] good like yeah
yeah like he was very much teetering on
everything like he wasn't really doing
anything special he knows it yeah like
he knows it i'm not saying his special
was bad there were moments where i saw
that special i laughed i thought it was
funny yeah that was a great funny moment
i liked it yeah for sure but it wasn't
it wasn't like a dave chappelle zero
[ __ ] given yeah because dave chappelle
might as well dave chappelle bill burr
uh [ __ ] louis ck
uh tom segura they should call all their
special zero [ __ ] given and even then
at that point kevin hart special was
nowhere near the level of freedom that
those specials ever had any of theirs
prior before canceled culture yeah even
after cancer culture so when he wrote i
think like he kind of shot himself in
the foot with his special people not
liking as much by calling it zero [ __ ]
given yeah he should have gave it a
different title people to enjoy it way
more but yeah you know yeah yeah that
that was something that like i was i was
peeping like the way that he was
advertising it you know saying
zero [ __ ] giving i don't i don't give a
damn and all these things
and but it just it just kind of seemed a
little forced yeah because it's like
it's not we we clearly see that you give
a damn it's like it's like dave
chappelle saying like he was like on one
of his specials he was like saying about
how kev you know apologized and then he
and kay was going on every interview
show saying that i'm not going to
apologize anymore while apologizing
at the same time you know it's just it's
just like it's like how safe or do you
want to be
how much do you really is it really
about your brand about money about who
you are genuinely
it's just it's just a it's a it's a
weird like wave and it's it actually has
me kind of like do i really want this
you know what i'm saying because it's
like yeah and you know on the rogan
podcast like kevin hart always he put it
well he's like i wish i could do what
dave chappelle does but dave chappelle
is a single entity dave chappelle only
has to worry about dave chappelle that's
it he kevin hart has a bunch of
employees under him so when he does
things and he ha and it has an adverse
effect
it's not so much about him it's about
the hundreds of people he employs
everybody's out of a job if he [ __ ] up
on the social space so he kind of put
himself in a corner where he now
realizes that yeah i i have to be very
careful about the things that i say even
if it's with the best intentions right
because like uh chappelle also put it in
his standup set about uh
when he made that joke he got kev got
[ __ ] roasted because of an old
stand-up set where he said if he found
out that his son was born right right he
tweet yeah he'd break a dollhouse over
his kid's head right which is clearly
[ __ ] ridiculous yeah he's exaggerated
right and the joke isn't about him being
angry that his son is gay is him making
fun of himself about not being able to
deal with homosexuality
you know it's the other way around it's
not that he's admonishing gay people
he's making fun of himself for being a
shitty father for not for not being able
to deal with the fact that his son's gay
that if you listen he actually did that
in a whole set it was him making fun of
himself yeah but people don't want to
hear that [ __ ] they want to go ahead and
grab that little [ __ ] clip and don
lemon wants to go ahead and mouth the
[ __ ] off about some [ __ ] when you didn't
even see the full set yeah cause you got
and everybody knows like i [ __ ] with the
lgbt community i'm mad supportive of
that [ __ ] right that's why what the baby
said was [ __ ] mad offensive yeah but
bro i have gay friends and they saw that
set then they were cracking the [ __ ] up
and they said the same thing they're
like yo he wasn't making fun of my
community he was making fun of the fact
that he's a shitty father he doesn't
know how to deal with the son being gay
right so you know context does matter
and people can absorb it the way that
they want but for me when i saw that
stand-up set i was like he's not making
fun of gay people yeah or that's how i
felt anyways but you know like i said
everybody else can feel the way that
they want and they're completely valid
for it too i guess yeah man how do you
feel about uh cancel culture
castle culture is just [ __ ] dumb
like what are you what are you doing
here yeah you know like i think that
canceled culture should just be like if
you don't [ __ ] with them don't support
them with your money and move on yeah
but when you try to apply cancer culture
to comics whose job is to go ahead and
push like push boundaries yeah and say
offensive [ __ ] and try to make fun of it
you're kind of [ __ ] up a realm where
it was an area for all of us to feel
free with our thoughts right whether
we're right or wrong right you could you
could go right now go online and go on
youtube and watch watch this clip of
patrice o'neill just being patrice
o'neill with louis ck louis ck says n
word with the hard r yeah i'm not saying
like as a joking around with patrice
o'neill right and patrice is cracking
the [ __ ] up yeah right i'm not saying
white people should go around saying
that [ __ ] but within the conversation of
their friendship of x amount of years
right they developed a relationship and
they understand that they're joking with
each other this is what a lot of [ __ ]
comics do yeah we joke around and we
[ __ ] roast each other all the time
exactly what we [ __ ] that's what i
talk about like how i talk about with
you like there's there's specific
conversations that we can have you and i
can have uh texting each other or like i
hit you up whatever like that's just
that's the conversation that we're
having now you know this one we're
recording you know i mean and we and and
we'll have um you know some things that
you know would be kind of edgy or
whatever but at the end of the day it's
like there's there's where we're
comedians we're we're we're um like i
guess i guess i guess i don't know i
guess do comedians have a uh more of a
uh what is it a past a pass yeah i think
comedians should have a pass when it's
in the comedy club when it's within the
comedy club as long as it was trying to
be funny and not harmful
give it a pass you don't got to laugh at
it and if you don't laugh at it it
destroys the joke that's all that it is
right so for example we go back to that
tony hinchcliffe thing right tony
hinchcliffe's biggest crime was the fact
that his the asian jokes just weren't
funny yeah that's why it was offensive
it just wasn't [ __ ] funny yeah i've
heard of plenty like asian jokes that
some asians would consider uh offensive
and i thought it was [ __ ] hilarious
because it was delivered well yeah right
so what are we talking about here right
so
as long as the joke makes sense and it's
funny then most people won't care
if it's not funny then people will
people are going to give a [ __ ] like
with the whole shane gillis thing right
yeah
we go back to that shane gillis clip
there's only like one clip of it on the
internet and this was the guy if you
guys don't know shane gillis was
supposed to be on snl he had a podcast i
believe it's with his brother or cousin
but they're basically making fun of
chinatown and saying like neuters and
they're doing like a really terrible
asian accent which you know as two
[ __ ] white males you guys should know
like the history with racism and white
people and like how you guys made fun of
asian people about our foods and our
accents and stuff it's gonna be a touchy
sensitive subject yeah but if it's funny
we're all good to go yeah and joe
rogan's argument behind that was that oh
you know comics always just work out
jokes there was no jokes in that [ __ ]
joe like i'm good with it if it's jokes
but where was the jokes it was just them
[ __ ] on [ __ ] asian people saying
our food is dishonest and it's [ __ ]
dirty there wasn't any jokes like if
they were like is dishonest and dirty
and a joke led up with it i was waiting
for the joke yeah yeah yeah and it
didn't happen it was like oh you just
you just said it yeah he just said it
like like you're just [ __ ] on us
like bro like what the [ __ ] is that
about yeah so when joe says that oh
when joe rogan looked at that and he
goes oh yeah like comics need to just
work the material out joe that wasn't a
joke that was a podcast and he was
having an honest conversation about what
he thought about chinese people in
chinatown yeah so
that's where people had an issue with it
doesn't take away from the fact that i
think shane gillis is funny shane gills
has some funny ass sketches online yeah
after i saw that clip it's not like i
was like [ __ ] shane gillis forever right
i'm saying in that moment you [ __ ] up
and you got cut from snl you got your
just desserts however
you look at shane gillis's sketches
online they're [ __ ] funny
so yeah you know like i can go ahead and
say like i don't [ __ ] with your [ __ ]
right here yeah i'm not outright trying
to say cancel them yeah right yeah but
i'm gonna have an opinion about the [ __ ]
that you put out right you can't you
can't just pawn that off as you saying
that it was jokes when it really wasn't
a joke i'm with that you know what i'm
saying but so do i believe in cancer
culture maybe to a certain extent but
when you kind of come at comics for
being edgy and saying like stuff that
doesn't really suit you
just because it offends you
you're allowed to feel that way yeah but
to go ahead and say hey at the click of
a button i could take away your life
yeah i could go ahead and make sure that
you never have to heart that i'm like
i'm not really i'm not like i feel like
cancer culture is just a community
just a community with
just you know they're they're they're
they have like itchy itchy [ __ ]
you know they gotta
just just a rim all like like ingrown
hairs on the rim of their butthole yeah
that's just like the the cancer culture
there's just a group that really try to
like they're trying to get you out and
yeah and and you're done like you said
they click little button you just
literally disappear but my thing is like
i don't think that's that's like
it's like it's like eminem you know like
are you really gonna try to cancel
eminem because eminem has his own fan
base his own stance basically that like
i'm probably canceled to you guys and
i'm canceled to cancel culture and i'm
probably not gonna have the same numbers
i know i'm not gonna have the same
numbers as what i did when i when i was
back when slim shady whatever but
bro he can still sell out a stadium of
his fans you know what i'm saying so
like do we really have to like
feel like we're canceled or or well
because people like cancel culture
because it's people who enjoy feeling
this small amount of [ __ ] power i did
that i was the reason why they can't
have a career because these people are
terrible yeah and you know people might
be [ __ ] i've heard this i said this a
million times on this podcast but it's
just idea
of human beings who are just [ __ ]
losers who enjoy a small little amount
of power and they just kind of get
carried away with it yeah they love it
they love the way that it [ __ ] feels
they love the fact that they're like oh
okay i'm over here i'm just i'm so much
better than you and i've said it before
a million times you know i would love to
bring out the skeletons out of your
closet
that's what i'm saying bro there's some
like i mean
you know i i like some kinky stuff bro i
ain't gonna lie dog i'm kind of a a
little kinky guy you know what i'm
saying but you know i i
i'll own up to it or i'll just be you
know it's with my girl whatever but like
you just gotta just you're just gonna
throw that out there just because you
just wanna [ __ ] with my whole like thing
you're like you know what i mean like
just to end something or like just to
say
you know what i mean it's just it's just
something to to really be like damn like
i can't really just live my life it's
virtue signaling people love getting a
pat on their back for you know
pretending to do the right thing yeah
you know and like i said
if you want to control what everybody
says it's not going to happen yeah and
in fact i'm even okay with people doing
[ __ ] up and stupid [ __ ] as long as
it's to your little small group yeah do
whatever the [ __ ] you want bro i
personally don't give a [ __ ] man yeah
you want to call like you know asian
people chinks and gooks but you do it to
your little subgroup and you don't say
that to an asian person yeah i'm fine
with it yeah keep it in your small group
and keep it in your [ __ ] mind and
that's it just don't spread it to other
people yeah right you get checked for it
yeah yeah yeah i can't control what
somebody does individually and i
guarantee you these people who always
you know spout online about you know
they virtue signal and they say that
they're perfect human beings i would
love to just go through any of your
[ __ ] dms any of your conversations
search histories let's talk about it
yeah let's talk about it yeah let's
let's see your pornhub uh uh history
that's right
[ __ ] my dad yeah
what's up what's up with that weird ass
[ __ ] search man bro i um yeah there's
uh there's there's there's some some
people like some weird stuff bro you
know what i'm saying and and it's like
those are the ones who
are counseling your [ __ ] business bro
yeah bro
ultimately ultimately bro you actually
will be better you would you would feel
better you wouldn't have so much pent-up
anger or like you know anxiety all these
things if you weren't so involved with
other people's business yeah you know
what i'm saying and i'm not talking
about stuff that
like i said just to reiterate what i'm
saying yeah it's like if we're talking
about social injustices that affect that
have a ripple effect in everything that
we do in life
these are these are different stories
i'm talking about somebody says
something that hurt your feelings
you know they're not like demeaning to
you right it's just
there's there has to be like a boundary
there has to be a certain point where
you're just like am i being too
sensitive or is this actually a big
issue yeah am i upset at this person
because they had this conversation with
their friends that i don't think that
they should be having let them just be
them yeah
it is what it is as long as they're not
going how to spreading this hate
anywhere else and they're joking with
their friends and once again i think
it's because i'm always like particular
about comedy because comedy has honestly
saved my life being able to make fun of
these weird and tough situations right
being allowed to kind of joke around
with these weird thoughts yeah uh that
may not be you know uh socially
acceptable all the time right
has given me sanity because it allows me
not to take everything so [ __ ]
seriously yeah because imagine what
that's like and a lot of people like
live like that you guys take everything
so [ __ ] literal and seriously you
guys die on the inside yeah man and it's
too hard yeah it's tough bro it's tough
it's tough for for others because it's
it's it's extremely
easier to just
scroll past something
turn your phone off or like turn the app
off or whatever than to actually type
out a whole
thought out you know why this isn't okay
and you need to be cancelled all these
things when it's just offensive to you
when really people are just like you
know uh uh
i don't know i it just it just seems to
me that like you know for me personally
i could just i can scroll past something
you know what i'm saying they can just
like keep it moving and it doesn't i
don't want that type of energy around me
you know what i'm saying so i like when
uh like i get on my mom about this stuff
like she watches uh good morning america
and then she goes to sleep before before
she goes to sleep she's watching the
news again and it's literally just
deaths murders uh this that before like
when she gets you up when she go to
sleep and i'm just like yo like you're
you're putting that into your your you
know into your world into your your vibe
your whole energy like that's really
happening you know i mean you're
starting your day off with all this
negative [ __ ] that like trauma porn
people love trauma porn dude that's what
it is trauma porn is people who
literally look for stuff for
traumatizing stuff and they feed off of
it right so for example there was a
filmmaker that got a lot of flack and
it was this short film that they put out
is supposed to be very poignant and i
think in this filmmaker's mind they're
thinking like oh this is the reality of
what slavery and racism was which we
already see representations of this like
in the real world right and
this filmmaker for shock factor and for
trauma porn worthy stuff had there was a
clip where they took the young black
child put it into a pillow case and this
and this racist white people these kkk
people were swinging it around in a
pillowcase smash this baby to the floor
why did you have to make a film about
that i know why you did that because you
thought it was gonna be some shocking
[ __ ] that was gonna get you awards and
that's trauma porn [ __ ] people feed off
of this type of stuff we see this as a
reality every day we don't need you to
recreate it in film because it doesn't
do anything right so when people wake up
and they watch this news of people being
[ __ ] up murdered and whatever whatnot
and all you're doing is tweeting about
it and getting angry about it but you do
nothing to fix the problem yeah what the
[ __ ] are you doing yeah i can't do it
bro i can't i can't watch i can't watch
you know i'm glad that instagram has
that blurry thing and it's like this
this is a graphic video
bro i'm good i keep i keep scrolling bro
i can't click it and watch it bro cause
like it could be something you know
somebody gets shot um or somebody breaks
a bone like all these things bro i'm
just like i can't it just it just makes
my stomach turn bro and it's
traumatizing bro like you're watching
the whole death on your phone you like i
watch this video of um
it was a video years ago of during uh it
was after 9 11 and there was like these
websites that were putting up two girls
no i still haven't seen that i refuse
i refuse
that's the first that's the first
traumatizing that's at that moment i was
like i don't have to watch bro anything
y'all show me there was this video clip
of it was
uh i didn't know what i was looking at
but it was a guy who was in the taliban
and he held it i i believe was like an
american journalist hostage and then he
sawed his neck off his head off
i did not expect to see that and i still
remember till this day hearing that
guy's scream and then when he cut his
vocal cord it went he was gurgling
and
i i was traumatized bro like shaking
because i don't like to see a human
being die like that was insane and i
don't know what the [ __ ] i was clicking
but it was a link that was going around
and i was like what the [ __ ] is is i
click clicked on it
traumatized i i can't look at [ __ ] like
that yeah i don't need to see stuff like
that yeah yeah i know i know that it
exists i know this world can be a
terrible place right i don't need to
hunt and look for those things in my
life yeah man it's crazy yeah no i can't
do it bro i can't do it just show me uh
show me some entertainment some some
some some tick talkers even random
prankers you know pranking people at
walmart which is a whole other uh world
and genre that i don't know how i feel
about it but hey they they're they're
doing it bro i know you know just look
up regular porn bro regular
know saying she's showing me some ass
regular consensual porn you know what
i'm saying hey do you uh is is uh this
is a question that was on my sister's
podcast um uh uh shout out to uh
ice uh combo shop okay
serving up serving up you flavors that's
uh my sister's podcast
shout out to mia sosa and ali um that's
her podcast so then they're shooting it
out of creative space houston plugs baby
um uh my studio in houston north side of
45 in 1960.
so um so
uh the question was
is a porn uh considered is watching porn
considered cheating
is watching porn considered cheating
yeah no
no why is it considered cheating is the
question
uh i mean that that's that this was this
was a poll that she put up and you know
she had you know it was like 50 50 huh
uh it was uh more like uh
60 40.
you know but but yeah there were people
there was like you know hell yeah the
[ __ ] my sister had like not at all
another one was hell yeah you know um
but uh i don't think i don't consider it
cheating i do i do think it's a little
weird when i when you see like you know
i remember uh i had a i dated this girl
man and the and the porn that she liked
watching was like the five guys on one
girl situation god damn and i'm like i'm
like
okay uh
like this makes me feel weird that's
what i'm saying like okay you know i
don't think it's cheating but it's like
what do you want like because this is
what really gets you off like yeah you
know she's like it's just so like gets
me so you know whatever and i'm like so
do you want four more dicks like what's
what's happening like what's what's she
no i don't know maybe you didn't ask her
no oh no i asked well yeah she was just
saying no i just like watching it she
said i just like watching it so out of
this world that's probably like what she
was she was saying like it's so extreme
it's a lot happening it's like it's like
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah you're watching you know
what i'm saying i was just i was like
okay well that makes sense you know i
guess you're watching something so
extreme that you do it's a fantasy type
of thing but it's like it's something
that you want or you you know i mean so
i i don't know if that's part of
probably the the the thought that you're
thinking of like why it could be
cheating it's like do you want i
understand like i i would say this
though that's a conversation that you
should have with your significant other
before you make things serious
like you should be like hey do you it's
like hey i don't like it when the person
that i'm with that i'm watching porn
like it's watching porn i was like cool
that means whenever i'm horny are we
gonna have sex yeah
probably not are you gonna give me a
hand job yeah i watch porn to save our
relationship yeah
sometimes i know you're tired yeah i
know i'm tired yeah so i just watch a
little porn and i whack it off and then
we have a good night's sleep and
everybody's good i don't want them i
don't care about them yeah like honestly
what i don't even think girls know
sometimes you know after that we watch
porn we watch some [ __ ] and then after
we nut we're like this is disgusting why
did i do this why am i watching this
we're not watching this you know what am
i why would i do this
i can [ __ ] do like [ __ ] i can make
like plutonium now yeah
yeah
i get mental clarity yeah bro
sometimes i just i don't want to have
sex though not because i don't think
you're a desirable attractive it's
because we got a shower after we got to
get cleaned out it's a whole ordeal
i could just shower knock one out and
then we good yeah we're good yeah yeah
man i um
i um yeah i actually i haven't even like
i haven't watched porn in a very long
time and i think it's because of how
much porn that i did watch i think i'm
sick [ __ ] bro i'm telling you bro at a
young age i don't know what this means i
would like to talk to a therapist about
this i don't know what it is bro but at
a very young age i was
super horny on a different level like i
really i enjoyed being home alone like
because when everybody get the [ __ ] out
bam when that when my mom when they're
like okay we're gonna go to the grocery
store you know what i'm saying in like
you know a lot i'll stay home i just
like right when they close the door i
hear the door lock i'm naked and i'm
like gonna be you know i'm i'm on the
couch or i'm like humping this or i'm
putting my penis my pee pee on this i'm
just like i don't know what it was bro
like
and you know i'm actually like you know
i'm being uh talking about this on on a
podcast but i mean sure this is real
[ __ ] bro that's what i did i was i was
making i didn't even know what a pocket
[ __ ] was i was making my own like
trying to you know uh put something to
put my dick in you know what i'm saying
i just made a [ __ ] fifi bro i would i
would i would use a uh i would uh roll
up a towel but then put a plastic bag in
it so where like you can uh like
basically you're [ __ ] in the in the
bag or whatever but you put lotion in it
i've made my own little makeshift
[ __ ] fleshlight oh work man bro i was
creative bro that was that was my first
creative space
that was the original creative space
houston
when you go to his [ __ ] place too
it's galaxies where you see stars that's
just come dude yeah
yeah bro come on down and it was crazy
is that that bro the way the universe is
bro i just really love like how god
blesses me with these jokes that i can't
even write bro um
there's there's like four different
sweets and the sweet that they gave me
was sweet d
hilarious i'm like thank you god why
would you cuz bro my marketing that i'll
be able to come on down 240 1960 sweet d
sweet d
you know what i'm saying like super like
dudes
douche yeah you know um but i've been
like that since i was since i was young
bro do you even like that now um i'm
like that now but it's more controlled
bro i mean yeah you know saying like i
know i i can control it and you know uh
i have that latino blood in you fully
you can't help it man i don't know bro
but i just hey some people are i'm like
the exact opposite like i i mean
obviously when i was younger i had that
stint like i remember i told the story
on the podcast where i remember i'd be
at the store and then sometimes some
financial woman would come through it's
my parents it's a black beauty supply
store got some thick-ass women coming
through i'm very young yeah and i'm like
i cannot focus i got to go to the
bathroom knock one out yeah so i could
catch people stealing yeah because right
now i'm giving them everything yeah you
want this you have it you want this you
have it yeah you know i like the um i
also like the um the thrill factor of
like we're in a movie theater
like you know saying or like we're in a
place where we shouldn't do it you know
you're jacking off in the theater
somebody's talking about no no no no no
no no i was like because if you're at
the peewee situation if you're jacking
off in a theater that means you're a
[ __ ] pervert yeah if somebody's doing
it to you you're a g yeah
yeah so definitely doing it to me for
sure uh palm bella handing off look at
that okay
no no no no bro it's um yeah man it's
just like you know uh like i've i've
done it at bro i've done it at runyon
canyon before like uh did you do it at
runyon canyon bro with like uh i i was
with the shorty where you know she was
down and we just went off in a tour bro
we actually which was so dumb because
you know you think that we can't see
them they can't see us but that was so
dumb because we went down everybody saw
you bro everybody the entire whoever was
at the top of the mountain they saw i
saw you guys looking down yeah for sure
for sure broad daylight i got anxiety
dick dude i can't even do that i
remember the first time a girl tried to
give me road head while i was driving it
wasn't happened i was like this is
dangerous stop
i was like i make it work bro i make it
work
i'm like i look i'm already asian i
can't drive and the fact that you're
sucking my dick 10 times worse get the
[ __ ] out
my i'd be like you know that that
spongebob episode where his big toe pops
out of his foot and like barely presses
it like i got my toes out of my out of
my shoes
pushing
like yeah man i uh i i don't know what
that means what what that what that term
is i just that's why this [ __ ]
cheats man
anytime he sees ass he's just like i
can't help it well you know i i now i am
definitely better he's learned i'm
definitely uh i i'm i'm so happy being
uh like single for the for the reason of
like i really had to figure out what
does that even mean when people are
saying when they're like well i just
need to learn how to love myself i just
need to learn how to love myself or i
just need to um you know master being
alone i have to i had to really like
figure that out like what the [ __ ] is i
generally like did not want to be in a
relationship because of my last one i
didn't want to be in a relationship that
was the only thing that was keeping me
single because of the last one i was
like i really don't want to do this [ __ ]
again yeah you know what i'm saying but
then it started instead of like working
against it of like i don't want to be in
one it ended up being like i want to be
alone i want to be single i want to be
able to do whatever the [ __ ] i want to
do yeah i want to be able to not have to
consider somebody else's feelings
because of something that i want to do
that makes me happy you know what i'm
saying like this is this is who i am and
i'm not denying it i'm not you know i'm
saying like i i just want to be
completely honest and i found it to be
way better you know what i'm saying to
just like tell them like yo this is how
i roll this is how i am um i don't want
to commit to anybody i don't want to
commit to you i want to just commit to
what i got going on and and you know a
lot of women [ __ ] with that though
they're just like you know what i'm not
looking for any commitments either i'm
just here to have fun because be
surprised yeah well yeah because there's
like this weird rhetoric that only guys
are like this like bro
it's people are like this yeah a lot of
people who just don't want to commit at
a certain time in their life yeah i
think you were in a place too where you
were in a committed relationship when
you were in a commitment space to be in
and so it just [ __ ] everything up yeah
man and you kept on trying to be
something that you weren't yeah i'm not
excusing your [ __ ] disgusting
behavior
[Laughter]
but now that you know better yeah now
the next time you're in a serious
relationship you'll know when you're
ready you're like oh absolutely i'm good
yeah yeah for sure and and it actually
has to be
like it can't just be oh because she's
you know she's super attractive or
amazing body like that was my my main
thing bro like that was my thing like
when i was when i was back uh uh you
know out here i always felt like i had
to
you know uh be in the relationship with
like the baddest chick that i've met i'm
like okay you're the one yeah that's
cause she's bad you know what i'm saying
and [ __ ] don't mean [ __ ] that doesn't
mean [ __ ] anything at all that's one two
i'm not doing
uh a non-funny girl anymore i mean i
might do you but i'm saying like i'm not
i'm not gonna be i just cannot bro i
can't fake laugh bro and if i do fake
life it'll be because you know there's i
have i have intentions you know i'm
trying to like have goals here you know
what i'm saying but either way you know
i don't want to be you're gonna be in my
life forever and like i have to just
like really be i mean like being with
somebody that on the physical scale that
is fine as [ __ ] is always a bonus like
to me
like maybe it's because i've
uh like i'm always personality based
like i got to just be able to be around
you yeah like i could literally care
less sometimes what you [ __ ] look
like especially because look at your boy
wearing orange socks and some turquoise
shorts and a white let me tell you
something man i don't give a [ __ ] right
your songs are like little towels hey so
this is a company called cozy warrior
shout outs to my friends jeremy they
definitely look cozy for sure yes they
are so this actually if you guys buy
socks it actually helps people who are
having trouble conceiving kids and they
actually it's a non-profit and they
actually donate money to people who are
in the ivf process look at that but also
i'm cute as [ __ ] in these
just to let you all know yeah but yeah
personality speaks so much because i
have to be around you yeah i have to
talk to you i have to have like a
connection with you and i i i say this
i'm not saying that people physically
who are beautiful are vapid or they
don't have any personality at all but
it's for me and my personal experience
you guys do have some personality but a
lot of them they don't because
if they were beautiful their whole life
everybody told them that they were
beautiful yeah everybody gave them
everything they didn't have to have a
personality they didn't have to prove
their worth for anybody they just had to
show up smile and then walk out which is
a gift and a curse bro which is dope for
you yeah it's it's great but it's also
like
it sucks because they also know that if
they if they're really like you know in
tune with themselves you know what's up
you know what i'm saying and that's
always a good thing when you when you
when you can really look at yourself um
uh those who are just like they you know
i'm funny i swear i am i i'm funny
everybody laughs at my jokes like no no
you're not you're not
when you say that that tells me that you
know you're not you just have to have
this whole thing or like oh no i'm funny
oh trust me i'm funny you don't have to
say you're funny if you say you're funny
you're literally the most unfunniest
person ever because funny people don't
ever think that they're funny
they never do they just think that
they're just talking and people just
happen to laugh
yeah and that's just how it is listen
a few years ago i met one of my like
crushes right not something i love i
love my fiance she's she's my real
number one crush i'm talking about like
my like like before i met her like
somebody who i lusted after right a
celebrity crush
met this person had like an hour
conversation with them and i'm like yep
you killed it
you [ __ ] killed it that's what i'm
saying because this person as beautiful
as she was yeah had to constantly talk
about how amazing she is about how smart
she is because she's always trying to
prove oh i'm more than just my looks
it's like i just met you yeah what is
with this comment you have literally
talked about yourself and how dope you
are for an hour i barely got a word in
edgewise yeah like this is this is how
exhausted you have so much weight on
your shoulders about proving who you are
right without actually knowing who you
are it's like what the [ __ ] it's like
i've done this i've done that i am this
person i've done that yeah cool
hi my name is david yeah yeah yeah
so there's like there's the you know
like once again this is a very general
blanket not everybody's like this but
i'm just giving a few examples there's
like the ones that have no personalities
and there's ones that are trying to
overcompensate because they know that
they're beautiful right but they just
don't i don't want to just be the looks
i'm also brains i can yeah
like and and it's just it's just as
worse i'm funny
yeah exactly
i'm doing stan you've seen those people
bomb you've seen them bomb so bad and
and and you're just like and oh man and
my thing is like i mean everybody's
gonna bomb in the comedy world but you
know it's just
consistently yeah it's it's a it's a
whole other thing man they're like the
uh they're the versions of the guy
comics that only do dick and sex jokes
yeah and those are the girl comics that
only do like [ __ ] guys want to [ __ ] me
jokes yeah it's like that and and i like
giving head and it's like when it's in
the back of my throat i'm like okay uh
breathing do we have do we still do that
like it's like it's like what do you
what do you really what what's what's
the joke yeah you know it's like i give
really good head yeah
so i'm giving ahead and it's about an
hour right i'm like still going and i'm
like
okay all right dude those comics every
time they go up i'm like please i'm here
to laugh like you're [ __ ] killing me
please don't do this i know that you're
[ __ ] home girls when you guys were
sitting around drinking my ties were
like
you know what yeah you're faint hey well
on the contrary all right on the flip
side of that i uh i said this recently
um because i was really just peeping
like you know the the olympics the um
the accomplishments of um um just women
in general you know saying i'm really
proud of my sister uh uh you know and
and and you know allie her co-host
they're really trying you know they're
really not trying they're they're really
they're doing it they made a podcast out
of my out of my place and and um you
know simone biles and jordan childs and
sue like that whole uh uh forever for
forget the the fighting for you know i
mean like like women have really been
killing it bro and that right there is
like that's my new like little turn on
like like i'm like oh that's sexy bro
like of course like accomplished women
who kill it are the [ __ ] best because
no some some will get intimidated by it
you know what i'm saying oh not me
because i'm looking like hey you trying
you trying to take care of daddy man
i'm like bro when i saw i i went to um
uh uh you know shout out to uh to michi
man michi she she works over uh with the
um
uh the usa gymnastics and she was over
uh working for simone biles and her gym
and all these things and um
she invited me over to the gym the the
champions gym that uh simone biles has
in houston in spring in the same area
that my studio's in um she uh she has a
gym there and we're watching the live
streaming of the the first um day that
she made the decision that she's not
gonna compete and we're just there we're
supporting we're watching but when i saw
the girls step up and i saw like jordan
childs i was like
girl
like when man like i mean obviously
she's a very attractive girl she's very
you're very pretty jordan i don't know
if you're ever going to see this but if
you do
um yeah you're no there's a lot of guys
are intimidated by women's
accomplishments because that's just some
inadequacy that they see in themselves
you know when you're a boss and you see
another chick boss up come on it's great
man come on even on the flip side too
because we're talking about you know
like the female comics who have friends
who tell me hey you should be a comic
guys have the same [ __ ] yeah it's like
this dude that's funny in a [ __ ]
group yeah of their friends and they go
up and they bomb and then they don't
even know why it's like i'm funny to my
friends it's like yeah you're funny to
us yeah but you're not a comic that's
just a [ __ ] craft like being a
stand-up comic is [ __ ] hard like even
i'm not a stand-up comic right now and
you know that just scares me to [ __ ]
death and i've done it for years it's
hard [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah man like i always
see the version of that it's like that
dude that he's probably like a really
good looking guy he was the popular jock
and he's like oh yeah all my friends
laugh around me like it's gonna be
really funny right hey so like uh i'll
give you a great example i have this
dude i had a lot i had a long
conversation with him before in the past
but i basically cut ties with him and i
just called him a [ __ ] loser but he
i saw him do stand up and he was talking
about he's like such a better stand-up
comic than me which i don't know why you
would ever say that you know i'm like
okay well let's see what you got he goes
up first thing he opens up with he does
like a small asian dick joke crowd is
silent it's like
get the [ __ ] off the stage bro yeah like
i know your friends told you you were
funny you're not [ __ ] funny yeah and
he sticks to it tries to do the same
joke and i'm like bro this is not funny
yeah at all
so i like to
like i have a nickname for my dick
everybody's already like
my god dude here we go get the [ __ ] off
the stage yeah [ __ ] are you talking
about man and everybody was drunk and
they still didn't find them funny it's
like come on guy sit the [ __ ] down man
yeah it's just hard like at least like
try to run your jokes by somebody this
is it's a crap and it's okay if you bomb
like i've bombed more times than i've
been successful but
that's never going to be funny yeah
straight up bro it's it's it's i don't
know man i uh just just
for me it's just
being
um
as honest as you can and you know timing
that also goes with it and then you know
there's also formulas when it comes to
delivering a joke but um
if it's coming from a genuine place
that's really my own that's my only
little like secret as far as like stand
up i'm just real i'm just being real of
what my
my story is now i don't want to go super
storytelling because i know that that is
a thing and i i i
that's that's like my um my strength but
if it is going to be a story you have to
punch it up within the story you can't
just be telling a story bro yeah because
you're telling us a story yeah it's a
ted talk it's a it's a get to the point
situation it's like what are we talking
about you have to keep that thing
punched up every other sentence you know
what i'm saying and so um there's a
there's a you know there's a it's a it's
a strategy you know i mean it's hard man
like and also too something that i used
to do a lot when i was younger is uh
when i first started doing stand-up and
i think every stand-up comic does this
is we get when we don't feel like we're
getting the laughs that we get we we
start being inauthentic and and stop
being genuine with our jokes and we
start getting loud and start being
really hacky yeah because we want people
to have a reaction
and then when we get older we're like
you know what i am funny yeah like the
[ __ ] that i have here is enough i don't
need a you know [ __ ]
you know
clownery [ __ ] right which you know if
you're a physical comic that is what it
is but i did that a lot and i still have
that habit now where i did that a lot in
case i wasn't getting a laugh yeah
sometimes you have to know you're enough
and if you're not it's okay for people
not to laugh that's a big one man yeah
knowing that you're enough like when you
because when you see somebody um trying
to be funny and you know that they are
like they think they really have what it
takes to be a great comedian you just
see them really reaching or trying to be
funny a little loud screaming yeah man
like and actually you know what bro uh
oh i used to go to this this open mic
called marty's and marty was the guy who
owned the the open mic and it was
literally a gym for for open micros or
comedians to go you know uh you know try
out their jokes work on their material
and uh there's one this specific time
where i was performing um working on my
[ __ ] and he had two rooms there's
another room where there was another
stage and he was in that room but he
comes out when i'm while i'm still on
stage i think i'm finishing up
but um or maybe i got off either way he
told me he was like um
you know you're you're you're screaming
you know you're really loud when you're
on stage and you're um
um i don't remember you being that you
know i've seen you a couple times and i
know you're probably trying something
new but he was like just because you're
loud doesn't make it funnier dude that's
real [ __ ] straight up bro
i'm over here like damn and
i'm a student of the game so i love [ __ ]
like that bro i don't get offended i'm
not in any place where i'm just like
which well i got it i got it bro you
know what i'm saying like but now look
how real that [ __ ] advice is it's
real and i had to find that [ __ ] out the
hard way i had to look at oh i had to
look at old clips of myself and i'm like
why the [ __ ] didn't anybody tell me yeah
you know yeah i'm like yeah they're
laughing yeah i guess yeah you know but
i didn't have to do all that the joke
was funny yeah you should have just
delivered it better you didn't have to
scream yeah 100 bro it's crazy man yeah
growth dude growth [ __ ] well guys that
wraps up this episode of the genius
brain podcast you guys can catch chris
at chris sosa uh christino so christino
social crisis
if you're out in the houston area you're
looking for a venue to book out whether
it's stand-up [ __ ] podcast stuff i don't
know they got they got a cyclorama they
got all this other [ __ ] out there it's
honestly a dope creative space for you
guys to go and check out he has very
competitive pricing and it's my boy man
and you best believe we're gonna do a
genius brain live show out there so yes
bro it's gonna be [ __ ] fun dude you
hyped bro i was so hyped when you when
you like brought that up to me yeah you
know what i'm saying when you were like
yo we got to do a show we do a live
genius brain show i'm like bro [ __ ] yeah
dawg like we gotta do that bro and i
definitely look forward to doing it
we're gonna do it soon bro definitely
before the year ends oh it's gonna be
this year for sure we're gonna we're
gonna do a genius brain houston show so
get ready for that chris is gonna be
there i might fly out a couple of the
other boys out you know it's gonna be so
that [ __ ] go bro hell yeah bro i would
love that man yes definitely if you are
in the houston area and you you are
creative and you need a creative space
to work in and uh my place definitely
when you walk in you feel that energy it
demands creativity let's go yeah bro for
sure and um you're going to love it so
let me know hit me up and you can also
follow uh creative space houston it's
called it's creator space houston on ig
and um follow us and check out what we
got everything i ain't gonna lie i'm
gonna toot my own horn right now every
post that i've been posting up with the
studio looks clean man it's it's fresh
it's dope and make sure if you're on the
houston area or anything else follow
chris of course he's a stand-up comic
that's his main trade so you got to make
sure you catch his shows catch the
funnies this guy's [ __ ] hilarious
yeah see that show laugh your ass off
and build this boy up thank you so much
for i appreciate you for having me on
man and growth we'll see y'all next time
peace